he's a great guy though who dies really
here's the last thing I want to say
though this is that I remember when you
and I had that beef he still let me open
for oh my god I just brought up a good
one
go ahead so dice goes you know Kate Jing
he's gonna be Chang you know I mean
itching thank God I'm not the only race
and he goes open for me Bally's it was
the Bally's or it was me joy ideas we
were together it was start outside I
think that was when he was with his wife
Oh still yeah but you were there I
remember you're with the kids oh then
that was the one week and I babysat yeah
yeah you were there no patty Ross was
opening that weekend no I did it with I
know you were there because I remember
trying to avoid you I feel like this is
one of your it's nice I babysat one
weekend in Patty room which is the
opener you know that because the last
show okay just listen to my story okay I
was me fine Jim yeah Jim Norton Joey
Diaz I know that that was the lineup
right because I've talked to Joey and
Jim about that okay nice I believe you
well I am open for him for years and I
remember you being there am I wrong
definitely because I wouldn't have been
there the only time I was there not
Bally's oh you liked it I wouldn't fail
you you'd like it what I don't know what
I'm doing what's the other big one that
he did Bellagio that's where I was at
Bellagio
so Bellagio he did make that deal with
Marty oh [ __ ] I forgot his last name but
you know what Eric no one gives a [ __ ]
he died anyway but he gave a lot of
money yeah
and they used to run that Club in
Brooklyn that he started at so whatever
that Club he did do I don't know if I
ever went though well okay well then
we'll just let it go is it my
imagination it's right you really have a
[ __ ] up imagine I was my favorite this
was my favorite one
when dice and I were dating we used to
do these he was this is how he was
getting through his divorce he was
filming everybody at the Comedy Store
you remember that all right so he
changed all the lighting
like no no permission from Mitzi or
anybody so I would have a full tray of
drinks that I'd have to serve and he'd
be like no no I need you in the scene
put the drinks down I'm like I have
customers and he's like no just do this
real quick
and I'd have to do a [ __ ] scene and
I'll bring out watered-down drinks yeah
yeah yeah so this would he would do to
everybody and his favorite was to get
Bobby Lee in there so he had was it re
beat you up yeah yeah well yeah you
threw my yeah slam is part of this was
for his kids Bar Mitzvah yeah so it's
kind of Bobby's getting his ass kicked
this is a Bar Mitzvah film and it's just
like all the comics are like Caleb and
I'm home and he's like you want to watch
the tapes that I filmed tonight and I'm
like yeah sure
and then you come on and I just nod off
not intentionally baby yeah I don't know
yeah but he goes he's like what's your
problem with Bobby Lee and I'm like I'm
not getting involved I'm not talking
about it and he's like you you're trying
to prevent me from selling the show
aren't you
because Bobby Lee would help me sell the
show I go then have him help you [ __ ]
sell the show he was furious and nearly
kicked me out that night
[Music]